[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and welcome
to the Google Cloud Platform
Podcast.
I'm Francesc Campoy, a developer
advocate for the Google Cloud
Platform, I'm here with
my colleague, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: Hi.
I'm Mark Mandel.
I'm also a developer advocate
for the Google Cloud Platform,
and it's another
episode of our podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
very excited about it.
So I guess that most of you
have heard the first episode.
So just a little
bit of a summary
of what we talked about--
basically, we have a podcast.
And there are
three parts of it--
cool thing of the
week, the main content,
and the question of the week.
So before we start with
the cool thing of the week,
what are we going to
be talking about today?
MARK MANDEL: In
the main content?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
in the main content.
MARK MANDEL: OK, so
the main content--
we want to talk about
compute as a continuum.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: Which is kind
of the spectrum of what
we can do on cloud platforms.
I think it's interesting and
hopefully everyone will too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
I really like that you're
using continuum and spectrum.
It sounds very--
MARK MANDEL: It
sounds very fancy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Very scientific.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Everything
is very scientific.
Cool.
What about the cool
thing of the week?
MARK MANDEL: I'm pretty
excited about the cool thing
of the week.
I got to have the
chance to collaborate
with a very, very
well-known fellow,
by the name of Ilya Grigorik.
We're going to put a blog
post out on the Google Cloud
Platform blog.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: All about HTTP/2
and what Google Cloud Platform
does to enable HTTP/2.
You can read the
full article, but I
think the really big
takeaway which is really cool
is basically, we kind
of just do it for you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So really,
if you want HTTP/2,
put an HTTPS load
balancer on it,
and that's pretty
much all you need.
As long as it goes through
HTTPS, we do HTTP/2.
If you're that bingeing customer
and you go through HTTPS,
you get HTTP/2.
So you just get a
speed boost, which
is awesome, without really
having to do much work.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And for those that don't
know what HTTP/2 is-- I mean,
HTTP/2-- yeah, the
version two of HTTP.
MARK MANDEL: It's better.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sure.
But why?
Why is it better?
MARK MANDEL: So that is
an excellent question.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know
that one of the thing
is it's way faster because it's
able to basically-- the server,
rather than having to cache on
the client every single time,
the server is able
to predict what
they're going to ask for
and just send you stuff.
MARK MANDEL: So it
can do pre-loading,
which is pretty interesting.
So we can send stuff in advance.
It tends to use a
single connection so you
can do streaming a lot better.
So where we used to
do tricks before--
there used to be one
where you'd chart it
across different domains and do
all those sort of fancy tricks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: You have to
worry about that sort of stuff
as much anymore too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
MARK MANDEL: It does
really neat stuff.
It's well worth
looking at the spec.
It's not particularly long.
It's pretty neat stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I also
heard one of the things
that I liked the least
from web development, which
is when you have to put all the
images into one single image.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, you're
doing image spreads.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which
is so painful to do.
Basically, it's
not needed anymore.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it makes
things a whole lot easier.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's really cool.
And I really like
that-- the fact
that you can basically
forget about HTTP/2.
Just know that it's going
to be there for you.
You just need to download
balancer before and that's it.
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty cool.
It's actually really cool
in that we sort of have
experimentations in there for
quick support on some platforms
too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Which
is also very cool--
which is a UDP streaming
type of protocol
that some browsers support.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE] is kind of magic.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's magic.
I don't know how it works.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I just
makes everything faster.
I don't really know how.
MARK MANDEL: It's special magic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Cool.
So yeah, that's a cool
thing of the week.
A little reminder to
you, to our listeners,
if you have something cool
that you want to share--
MARK MANDEL: Love to have it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Let us know.
At the end of the podcast,
we'll repeat all the ways
you can contact us.
MARK MANDEL: Brilliant.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So for the main content--
compute as a continuum.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So this is really interesting.
So actually you had a really
good metaphor for this.
I really like it.
I actually really like it.
I kind of want to start there
with the metaphor you had.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
So basically-- well,
for the computer options
we have-- basically
you can say you
have the Infrastructure
as a Service or IaaS,
or whatever you pronounce it.
I'm very bad at
pronouncing that.
You have also platform as
a service-- PAAS or Paas.
And then there is
something in the middle
we'll discuss about later.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And I was thinking
how to make the
difference between both.
And well, I'm European,
and in Europe,
other than being just
in general better,
we also have manual cars.
MARK MANDEL: We have those
in Australia as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, but you drive
on the wrong side of the road.
MARK MANDEL: In America,
they call them stick shifts.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, wow.
OK.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we
have stick shifts then.
And I was thinking about
the difference between cars
and I asked-- driving a
manual car or a stick shift
and driving an automatic car.
But then I realized that
actually that's kind of wrong.
It could be more like when
you have Infrastructure
as a Service, you're
driving a manual car.
When you have PaaS,
it's basically
you are in a self-driving car.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I actually really,
really like this.
Because Infrastructure as a
Service is really like-- its
your infrastructure.
It's like you're
spinning up VMs.
You get just basic
machines, nothing on them.
It's totally up to you how
you wanted to do stuff.
If their stuff goes
down, it's on you--
all that sort of stuff.
Sort of like being
in a manual car,
if you want to change
gears, you have to do it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: If you want
to go faster or slower,
you have to break.
If you've been given a car, then
it's up to you to go forward.
And at the same time, you could
totally mess up your gear box
if you do it wrong.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: And that's on you.
That's totally on you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I may
have done that before, yes.
MARK MANDEL: I may have
done similar things.
But then, I really like
the idea as-- platform
is a service, where
you say to the car,
like if you've got
a self-driving car,
you're like, hey, I
want to go to the shops.
Take me to the shops.
And the car decides the
route you want to take.
It decides how to
get there, how fast
to drive, avoiding obstacles.
And so on platform as a service,
you don't have as much control,
but it's like, well, now I can
just get to where I need to go
and I don't have to do a
whole bunch of other stuff,
such as infrastructure
tasks or security as much,
or things like that.
So I actually really
like that metaphor.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And actually
following the metaphor
a little bit
deeper, you can also
have the thing
that is like, when
you need to learn how to drive
a self-driving car, well,
that's it.
You just get in the self-driving
car and it's just like drive
me to the store That's it.
Learning how to drive
a stick shift-- well,
that's a little bit more time.
So it's going to
[INAUDIBLE] a while.
Like when you are
a platform service,
everything you need to know
is what you want to do.
That's it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: When you have
infrastructure as a service,
you're going to have
to decide on what
OS you want to
run, what libraries
you are going to be using, how
do you secure your network.
MARK MANDEL: How do you log
it, how do you monitor it,
make sure it stays up-- yeah,
all that sort of fun stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah, I
really like that metaphor.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
I think that worked really well.
I really like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So how
do we offer those things
in Google Cloud Platform?
MARK MANDEL: So
Infrastructure as a Service--
we have Google Compute Engine.
So we can fire up
virtual machines.
You have a variety of operating
systems-- so Debian, Ubuntu.
We even offer Windows if
that's your flavor of choice--
and a few others as well.
We have a list online which
shows you which ones of ours
are supported and
how much server.
We do core OS.
We do all sorts of stuff.
But they are-- they
are basic machines.
We put some stuff in them to
make them a little more secure,
and ability to SSH into them
really easily, but that's it.
They're machines.
You can do what you like.
Any extra details I
might have missed?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Not really.
It's basically, you just
get virtual machines
and you do whatever
you want to them.
So you can do SSH,
do apt-get install.
You can mess around.
You can break your machine
down basically, and then
just delete it and create
a new one if you want to.
MARK MANDEL: Probably
most interesting--
you can do up to 32 cores,
we can do SSD disks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And there's all the
networking parts, load
balancers as we mentioned
before and so on.
So there's basically-- if
you walk into a data center,
like an ideal data
center, where you can just
say I want more and
more machine here,
and now I want to connect
them with this cable-- that's
basically what you do.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, yeah.
And you can usually provisioning
tools-- Ansible, Chef, Puppet,
all that sort of fun stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
There's also the monitoring
that comes directly from it,
so you can see how often
the machine has been used.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's
a lot of things going on,
but it's basically just basic
components of virtual machines
that you manage.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We do make
some things a bit easier.
Our monitoring service kind
of hooks in automatically
with the machines.
So that's one thing you don't
have to necessarily manage.
But, yeah, that's
Infrastructure as a Service.
That's compute engine.
You can spin up VMs.
So all the way on the other
side, Platform as a Service--
what have we got there?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
Platform as a Service
is one of my favorite products.
I use it all the time.
it's Google App Engine.
MARK MANDEL: Woo!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And what
Google App Engine does
is basically this idea
of a self-running car.
You write your code, you just
put it there, and that's it.
You don't need to
manage anything else.
You don't know
how many instances
are running-- just
like enough instances
to run the traffic
you're getting.
That's it.
So it's really easy
to get started,
but also it scales very well.
We talked about it a
little bit last night.
MARK MANDEL: On the
previous episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, because
the Google Cloud Platform
podcast is actually
hosted on App Engine.
But it's so simple to use.
You have huge, huge players
like Rovio with Angry Birds.
They use that and it
just works very well.
So basically, the good
thing is that you're
giving a little
bit of flexibility
that you have with
Infrastructure as a Service.
So you cannot run
everything you want.
You have like a series
of allowed runtime.
So you have Go, of course.
You have Java, you
have Python, and PHP.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And then
that's pretty much it.
There are some limitations on
how you can access the network
and things like that.
But it's kind of easy to
adapt any application to it,
but you still have to adapt it.
MARK MANDEL: It's
worth noting though
that you can't run your
own custom code on there.
You can't write to
the file system.
You have to go through
some of our storage.
Requests can take
longer than 60 seconds.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Stuff
like that-- and that's
kind of the way it's built.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
The limitations-- for
instance, the fact
that you can write
to the file system,
it's actually a very
good best practice.
Because if you try to do
that on a single machine
and the machine goes down,
you just lost the data.
MARK MANDEL: Sure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
for a web server,
it's actually a good practice.
So basically, we're
trying to enforce the best
practices for web development.
So then once you're doing
that, we can make sure
that your code will
scale to whatever traffic
you're getting.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It means we can do things that
make things easier internally
to be out of scale and
do stuff like that.
But much like your
self-driving car,
you can't be like,
oh, actually we
need to go faster or
take this shortcut
or something like that, for
very specific instances.
Like no, the self-driving car is
going to get you there the way
it's going to get you there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's it.
And I think most of the time
it's basically what you want.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
For me, by default,
I will develop stuff
for App Engine.
And if I get to some point
where I want to run something
like FFmpeg or Image
Magic, or things
like that, that won't
run on App Engine,
then I will spawn a
compute engine instance
on the infrastructure
service side.
And you can have both of them
make them communicate together.
So yeah, you can get
the best of both worlds.
MARK MANDEL: Best
of both worlds.
So speaking of best of
both worlds-- fantastic
segue-- we were talking a
little bit before about how
we can have stuff that sort of
sits in between Infrastructure
as a Service and
Platform as a Service.
And I think we have
a couple of offerings
that they're available there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so that's the good thing
that the word continuum
implies indeed.
Yeah, so we have both ends--
Infrastructure as a Service
on one side, Platform as
a Service on the other.
What's in between?
MARK MANDEL: So we have
a couple of things.
We just talked about App Engine,
and falling under that banner,
we have something that's
called Manage VMs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
That's cool.
MARK MANDEL: Which I think
is actually really cool.
Manage VMs pretty much lets you
to sit in the App Engine world
where we manage things
for you, but allows you
to-- I hate to use the term,
but it actually makes sense--
like break the glass ceiling.
We had to break through
and say, OK, I actually
want to be able to either
run my own run times
or write my own
code the way I want
to write it, and take
longer than 60 seconds--
things like that.
But I'm willing to give
up a little bit in terms
of either the management side.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So
pretty much we've
got Ruby support on there.
I actually have to remember.
Node.js.
A few other ones I can't think
of off the top of my head
right now.
And you can also provide your
own Docker files as well.
So you can bring your own
custom run times if you want,
and this way you can do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
the good thing about it
is that we've also been
working on the fact
that now you can
deploy to manage VMs
without having to install
Docker on your own machines.
So basically, you
just give the code
and we'll build
it and deploy it.
So the developer experience is
quite similar to App Engine.
It's pretty good.
Just write your
code and send it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and it's
meant to be very close.
So you can also still write
Java and Python, and PDP and Go,
much like you would before.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So if you have
an existing App Engine app,
and you're like, you know what?
For this particular
bit of my code,
I actually need to break out.
Maybe I need FFmpeg
like you were mentioning
before-- things like that.
I can still have
the infrastructure
that I'm used to
with App Engine,
but I can go that little
bit further and be like,
oh, I have a container, so I
can put whatever I like in it.
And that's really
powerful stuff.
I really like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So yeah, basically
that's just going a little
bit in the direction
of Infrastructure as a Service
but definitely next to Platform
as a Service.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's very
Platform as a Service A.
MARK MANDEL: A, yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do we have
something in the middle?
And the answer is,
of course, yes.
MARK MANDEL: Of course we do.
We have something, I think,
a little bit further more
towards the Infrastructure
as a Service side, but still
in that Platform as a Service.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's Kubernetes,
which, I love the name.
MARK MANDEL: So I have a
tendency to say Kubernetes.
I think it's just
because I'm Australian.
I don't know why.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I mean,
it's a Greek word anyway.
So I don't think that either
of us is pronouncing it.
MARK MANDEL: You know what?
Somebody should
definitely send us
a phonetic sounding--
someone who
has a Greek background--
I think that sounds great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh
yeah, that would be nice.
MARK MANDEL: We'll play it.
I think we should play it.
So Kubernetes is an
open source project that
was first started by Google.
We could talk about this
for an entire episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I think
we'll get some people on.
I've got some interviews
definitely lined up.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That could
be a nice episode too, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: But what we
have is a hosted version
called Google Container
Engine, which is essentially
hosted Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is
really, really cool.
The way I like to
explain it really
quickly is basically-- so
it's really a container
orchestration service.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: And the way
I like to think of it
is-- containers are great.
We could go on with
them for a while.
But what do you do when you're
like, I need five of these type
and 10 of these type, and
I need six of these type.
I need to make sure this one can
talk to that one, and this one
talks to that one,
and these two always
get started up together
and that sort of stuff.
That's what Kubernetes does.
So it's a scheduling service to
make sure that, hey, yeah, I've
got five running of this,
I've got six running of that,
I've got ten running of these.
And if the machine blows up or
a docker container goes down,
then it starts it back up
again, and says, oh, wait.
That's gone down.
Sweet.
And what's cool about
it, which I quite like,
is sort of the
ubiquity of containers.
It doesn't really matter
what's running inside them.
It doesn't matter.
Kubernetes can just do
it in a very standard way
for all sorts of different
types of software applications.
So I kind of like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and just to give a more
concrete example-- something
that I have seen, for instance,
is you have the typical--
the head of world
of the [INAUDIBLE]
existence, which is basically
the guestbook-- the
database that moves around.
I really like that
example because basically
what you're saying is, well,
you have the web servers.
And then you also
have a database.
When you have those
web servers, maybe you
want to scale-- the
web server container,
you want to scale it over.
And [INAUDIBLE] is like, oh, I
had one container doing that.
Now I want to have 10 of those.
And maybe have five hosts- five
actual machines running that.
And you don't want those ten
containers running, all of them
in one single machine.
So you want to say, oh, yeah,
just [INAUDIBLE] across.
And that's what
Kubernetes will do.
If one of those five
machines goes down,
those two containers will
just move somewhere else.
That's it.
So basically it's
the idea of you
describe what you
want to have running.
That's what we call the
declarative approach, where
you don't say what to do
when something goes wrong.
You just say this
is what I want.
Do everything you
need to make that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So you still have the
ability to drive the car,
but there is some
self-driving aspects to it.
It is really in that
middle, isn't it?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I kind of like to
think about it--
you're basically a self-driving
car, where you're basically
saying you know what?
I actually want to go
through these streets
and I need to avoid that part.
So it's more like very,
detailed self-driving.
MARK MANDEL: Sort
of like lane assist
or self-parking or
something like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Just to
go into that metaphor.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, at some
point that metaphor will break,
I'm sure.
So that's Kubernetes.
And Kubeternetes--
basically what it does
is it's just that--
orchestrate containers
across a fleet of machines.
Those machines can be running
on Google Cloud Platform,
on Google Container Engine.
They could also be
running somewhere else.
They could be running
on your own premises.
They don't be running
anywhere else.
What Google Container
Engine is, is
just Kubernetes-- the whole
thing is managed by one master.
So what we're doing
with Kubernetes
is giving you an easy way to
spawn those instances that you
need to run the containers, and
then one extra instance, which
is what we call a Kubernetes
Master, that is managed by us.
So we make sure that that
machine will never go down.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
that's the important one.
It's pretty easy.
It's pretty awesome.
You can go to the Developer
console, click a button.
How many nodes do you want?
I'd like five, please.
You click OK, and
it spins it all up
and creates it for you,
which is pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's a very, good experience.
I really like it.
MARK MANDEL: I really,
really like it too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
should definitely
do an episode on Kubernetes,
because there's really
cool things.
MARK MANDEL: There's
so many cool things.
OK.
So to recap, I guess-- so
on one side of the spectrum,
we have Platform as a Service.
So we've got App Engine.
And then as we
continue a little bit
further towards
Infrastructure as a Service,
we have Manage VMs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We continue
a little bit further
towards Infrastructure
as a Service.
So we've got Container Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: And Kubernetes.
And then we go all the way
over on the other side--
Infrastructure as a Service--
we've got Compute engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So that's
the continuum really.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's it, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That
seems pretty cool.
So really, whatever
you want to build,
we should have a
solution for you
and hopefully we can help you
along the way as well with
some of our tools.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I think that basically,
anything-- and the good thing
is that there are
some solutions that
will work very well for
Infrastructure as a Service,
and some other things,
Platform as a Service,
some other things
more like Kubernetes.
But the good thing is that
you can use all of them
at the same time.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's nothing
that forces you to go with one.
You can just pick and choose.
MARK MANDEL: Pick and choose.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Lovely.
All right.
I think that sounds
really great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So for the last
part of the podcast,
we have a questions of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
We have a question of the week.
So this seemed to
be around someone's
trying to SSH into their
machine from their laptop--
from like a terminal command.
And they're like-- this
is an interesting one.
So they know their
details are correct.
So I'm sitting at my machine
and I know my password.
And my credentials are
all set up correctly.
But every time I SSH in, it
keeps dropping my connection
and I'm really confused
about what's going on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So that happened to me once.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
was quite painful
because-- if you know
Linux enough, probably
you know exactly
what is the answer.
I'm not a Linux expert
so it got me confused
a little bit for a while.
MARK MANDEL: So I like to
think I'm a Linux expert.
I have been using
Linux for a long time,
but I actually didn't know
the answer to this at all.
So I thought this was
actually really interesting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So basically if you
tried-- every single time
you tried to SSH or actually
to connect in any way
to a Compute Engine
instance, there's
going to be a log
going on somewhere.
We're going to--
just in case we want
to measure-- if someone
is trying to attack
you-- these kind of things.
MARK MANDEL: Security stuff.
Good stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So if you're running
Ubuntu, by default,
you have this little
program called Sshguard.
I'm not sure if I'm
pronouncing it correctly.
MARK MANDEL:
Sshguard-- I think that
sounds-- between the two of
us, I'm sure it will be fine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's
Ssguard-- something like that.
And what Sshguard does is
every single time there's
a connection event-- so as
someone is searching into it--
we'll measure the dangerousness
of the connection.
MARK MANDEL: So like
how risky it is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
How risky it is.
MARK MANDEL: It seems
a little bit strange.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And the things that when you're
connecting from your laptop--
it turns out that very often
there's some DNS settings going
on, and basically your laptop
appears as something slightly
risky for that instance.
It doesn't mean it's
completely risky,
but it doesn't really trust it.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So it
gives the dangerousness
of 10, which is a completely
random number to choose.
But the thing is that
once you get over 40,
then you get banned.
So that's why you may be
able to get it once, twice,
three times.
And the fourth time your
connection is dropped.
And the only error message
you get is your connection
is dropped.
MARK MANDEL: So it's not
like you're reconnecting
a lot over a short period.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Basically, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: After a
while, it goes down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: After
a while, it goes down.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so
what's the solution for that?
Well, the first
thing you need to do
is you need to make sure that
that's actually the problem.
Maybe your network is not broken
and you're not able to connect.
So that could be.
So how do you connect when
you cannot SSH into a machine?
Well, what is going on is that
your IP has been banned, right?
But you can still connect
using the console.
From the console, you
have the SSH button.
That will work
every single time.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So Google Cloud Platform
knows for compute and SSH,
if it's doing it
through the browser,
it's like oh, that's special.
We know that's great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We know who
you are when you're using
a private key identification.
So it's different.
MARK MANDEL: So you're probably
logged in with two-factor auth
because we're all using
two-factor auth when
we use our Google accounts.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
all should, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So we trust
that connection a lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so that's the thing.
That will always work.
Then once you
connect in there, you
can do IP tables dash capital
L, so pseudo IP tables,
depending on who you are.
And that will list
all the rules.
Probably you're going to find
one of those little things
that your IP has been banned.
You can just drop it, so just IP
tables dash help or something.
You'll see how to drop it.
It's quite simple, and once
you're dropped it, that's it.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Now you're allowed
back in again.
Can you white list yourself and
be like, OK, am I always OK?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
You can white list yourself.
Depending on the
instances and the rules
that you have on
your connection,
it may be harder or easier.
One of the things that you can
do is just say this is my IP.
Don't ever block this
IP, and then you're good.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
That sounds great.
All right.
Cool.
Good to know.
If I'm ever locked out of
one of my own machines,
now I know what the
problem could be.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it's good to know.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Great.
All right.
Great.
So finishing off, why
don't we just recap
with what events
we have coming up,
if people want to
come and talk to us
or talk about Google Cloud
Platform-- where we'll be.
So Francesc, where
are you going to be
headed the next little while?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I'm going to be--
so there is [INAUDIBLE] that
is happening very, very soon.
I'll be there.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Then in November, I
will be in Oradev
in [INAUDIBLE].
Then I will go to
Paris for dotGo.
It's a Go conference.
Then I will go to--
what's the name--
Devoxx in Antwerp in Belgium.
We're going to have a
huge, huge team there.
I think we're going to be like
five or six of Google Cloud
Platform.
MARK MANDEL: It sounds like
it's going to be a good event.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That's going to be lots of fun.
And then after that--
the week after that,
I'm going to Barcelona--
not for holidays this time,
even though I have some.
But because there's
Docker Con Europe.
MARK MANDEL: Very good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Great.
So in November, I will be
at FutureStack conference.
Super excited about that
because Steve Wozniak will
be keynoting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, wow.
MARK MANDEL: I'm on the speaker
page with Steven Wozniak.
That made me pretty happy.
And as I mentioned
in the last episode,
I will be at Closure
Con in November
as well talking about some
container stuff and development
environments, which should
be lots and lots of fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds cool.
So yeah, if you are
anywhere around there
and you get the
chance, come say hi.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, love
to speak to everyone.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Send us a message on
Twitter or through an email.
So just in case,
let's remember that.
So our website is
gcppodcast.com.
Twitter it's @gcppodcast.
Google Plus
google.com/plusgcppodcast.
What else?
I'm forgetting something.
Reddit.
It's r/gcppodcast.
And our email is
hello@gcppodcast.
I think that's it.
MARK MANDEL: I think that's it.
That seems like everything.
All right.
Well it was great to chat
with you once again, Francesc.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And talk to you next week.
MARK MANDEL: See you next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING] s